-Our next guest
is a talented actor
you know from shows
such as "The Walking Dead"
and films such as
"Okja" and "Burning."
He serves as executive produce
and star
of the Golden Globe
award-winning film "Minari,"
which is available
everywhere now.
Let's take a look.
[ Conversing in Korean ]
-Whoo!
-[ Speaking Korean ]
Whoo!
-Whooooooooooo!
-Please welcome to the sho
Steven Yeun.
How are you, Steven?
-Hey, good.
Nice --
Thanks for having me.
-Hey, congratulations so muc
on the win.
I assume it was both thrilling
and a little disappointing
not to all be able
to celebrate together.
But what was it like last nigh
when you saw the victory?
-Um, you know, it was really
great to see Isaac
give that
really beautiful speech.
And, um, yeah,
it's been a bittersweet
entire press tour of this thing.
But also, uh, yeah.
I probably haven't figured out
what I feel about
pandemic yet at this point
[ Laughs ]
-I found, you know,
watching this film,
I think it would've been
an emotional experience
during any time,
but because it is
so strongly about family
in a time where it's hard
for us to see family,
I found this to be even more
of an emotional experience
to watch it during the pandemic.
-Thanks. Yeah.
I mean, I think
the feelings that went in
to making the film were,
you know,
it felt like connection.
It felt like us being able t
see each other a little clearer,
and hopefully, that's the thin
that's happening.
-You have
two young children yourself.
And I'm just wondering
if your kids are aware
of what you do for a living.
Have they ever seen you on TV?
I mean, "The Walking Dead" isn't
the most kid-friendly show
-No, they have not seen that
My kids are young.
They're now gonna be 4 and 2
And so, um,
they don't know what I do,
but they occasionally see me
pop up on a screen
here and there.
So, they're just
kind of confused about it.
I think they just think
I'm just --
I don't even know.
hey probably just think
I'm floating around
in the Internet all the time
or something like that,
and then I just pop up.
It's weird for them, I'm sure.
-This film,
you're so great in it.
All the adults are great in it
But it would not have worked
if these two child actors
weren't so exceptional.
Like, how lucky did you feel
when you first found them?
Because you must have known,
as also an executive produce
on the film,
that it was sort of --
I don't know -- live or di
on these performances.
-Yeah, those kids
are really wonderful.
They're just so pure,
and they keep you honest.
But I think, you know,
when we found them,
they were just
so locked in to the characters
And when we were filming,
they were so honest that,
you know, you can't mess u
or else they'll call you out
They were kind of policing u
all throughout the shoot.
So, they're aggressive,
those guys.
-You also had
not just a Korean cast
but you had almost entirel
a Korean crew.
What was that experience like?
Because obviously,
working in the States,
that's probably pretty unique.
-Well, you know,
it wasn't all Korean.
It was the heads of department
were Korean,
which were really cool to see,
making sure that
the authenticity and the share
experience was there.
But what was really wonderfu
about it was,
our crew was pretty mixed.
There were a lot of locals
from Oklahoma, where we shot
and I think the thing
that really resonated with m
at the end was, there was this
collective sense of ownership,
that it wasn't just, like,
this Korean film.
It was really just this, like,
beautiful film about famil
and togetherness, regardless
of where you come from.
And so that was really nice.
-I know -- I'm wondering,
your parents, obviously,
because of this difficult year
haven't been able
to see your kids much.
How have your parents been
in this sort of Zoom existence
that a lot of grandparents
are going through?
-[ Chuckles ]
I don't know if your parents
do this, but like --
are they, like --
they're like cracked out
for pictures.
-Yeah.
-Like -- they're like,
"Gimme --
Gimme the pictures."
Like, they'll text us, like,
every couple days, like,
"Hey, like, we haven't
gotten pictures in a while
Can you just, like --
Can you just lend us some?
It feels very off sometimes.
But I regularly get, "We liv
just to see these photos."
So we try to photo dump them
every couple days.
-Yeah, we've done this thing
where we have
sort of a shared photo album
And so my parents have tha
on their phone and yet,
I'll say,
"Did you see the new pictures?
and they'll say, "No."
And I'll say,
"Well, you gotta look, or else
we're gonna take you off
the shared album."
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- I don't think the
shared thing would work with us.
It would require
too much navigation,
so we just...
Photo dumps.
-That's way smarter.
I heard a story
that your mother,
and I guess maybe
it was a high school production,
you were in a school play,
and her feedback was
that you were not very good.
Is that true?
-Oh.
I mean, that's like --
I think that's most of them.
[ Laughter ]
No, it was a college production.
And then I remember I was like
"Mom, what did you think?
I just finished."
And it was like -- it was
liberating moment for me,
because I was up on stage
kind of for the first time
And I was like,
"What did you think?"
She's like, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
And, like, I've just been trying
to find my mom's approval
my whole professional career
So, um, I'll get there some day.
-Now, what did she think
of this film?
She must have liked this.
-No, she loved it.
I think for her, you know --
All Korean moms,
and maybe all mothers,
are the backbone and the unseen,
you know, powerful strength.
And so, for her, um,
me playing my dad,
or only being able
to play my dad,
I'm sure she was like,
"I wish I had a daughter
that could play me."
[ Laughter ]
"It would be more liberating."
-That's very fair.
I didn't even think about that
Well, the actress who played
the mother was also exceptional.
-Incredible. Yes.
-Very happy with that.
Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
Congrats on the win last night
Just a delight.
-Thanks very much.
Appreciate it.
-"Minari" is available
everywhere now.